my told me that you had a girlfriend I'm  not really available I slept with  someone I just met last night was that  [ __ ] you have a [ __ ] bar about you  bring it up a flame I thought it went  well well like a Scrabble game I had a  one-night stand now you're wearing is 90  I earned it you're not gonna get  obsessive mariya oh so what do you do  I'm a rabbi you're kidding  if you want to reconnect with your roots  feel free to come to my congregation boy  the Holocaust was a terrible business  wasn't it terrible business  and then watching it all no you're  glowing oh good yeah I feel like a  foreskin we have great sex what do you  think it means  don't do that what like you yeah why  doesn't make you like me laughs I wish  I'd never met you I could have put it  anywhere I could about anyone it's just  not worth it  if you're just bathing and your bras and  underwear killing two birds with one  stone  yeah but then you're just doing in your  own filth always  [Music]